rap trivia for anybody out there
listening I'm going to name four labels
okay
um let's see Luke records MH rap a lot
records Death Jam
records Death Row Records Insane Clown
was signed to
one does anybody know that was it Death
Jam yes yeah it was Death Jam yeah we
were on Death
Jam how ridiculous does that sound now
to me it's just like I remember [__]
Leo Cohen was it was was screaming in my
face oh my God tell me about that bro
like a thug I can't imagine Leo Cohen
getting you
guys I don't think he did but I remember
we we we were supposed to do these
Branch visits when we're on tour we go
in we're in the New Jersey Branch for
the label and we meet everybody you know
and um we were skipping that [__] you
know what I'm saying we just didn't want
to keep doing that we're tired and [__]
you know so we're just not anyway we got
to New York man and he [__] he was
like you think you're from the street
I'm from the [__]
Street you know what I'm saying and it
was just like you know and then he was
like now let's get to business
he was like I'll get you anybody he was
all sudden was cool as [__] he's like we
can get anybody you [__] want on a
record on a record right you name it
it's happening you know what I mean and
it went from I thought I'm about to
fight this dude right to now I want to
[__] the dude I was pause uh I was going
to say who who ended up bringing you
guys into the label like who was the no
what happened was we were on island
island and then and then Island merge
right okay mer and is was gone ah yeah
yeah I'm saying remember that yeah so
they kind of inherited you guys I
remember walking through the office at
Death Jam right and people are like what
is this Halloween the whole label cuz
they had no idea they yeah was just like
what the [__] is this and um here's the
funny thing
right we sold 2 million albums for
[__] Island right right our next our
next album is platinum right um we do
we do a double album and they both
almost go gold
right
now they just Def Jam let they just let
the contract expire we didn't get
dropped well you guys did that they
didn't resign I remember you guys
dropped two albums on the same day right
yeah that's what I'm saying you guys did
that before Nelly huh no cuz it was two
different albums you had to buy both
yeah you guys did that before Nelly cuz
Nelly did it but like y'all really I
think you guys are the first people to
be like man we did it we we did it cuz
he did it oh he the Judgment Day album
you know what I'm saying he did night
and day and back in the day and just
clocked on everybody you know it's like
yeah cuz your fans AR going to just buy
one [__] yeah they're going to buy two
and why would you combine them yeah yeah
[__] that you know but um yeah we here
we are you know what I'm saying and they
just let our contract expire yeah so
suddenly we signed with another label
for [__] million dollars wow who's at
the label the label was a new a new
label right and they were called um D3
D3 D3 entertainment D3 is um they had
Old Dirty Bastard they had us they they
they uh was that Quincy Jones son maybe
I'm tripping that's qd3 qd3 that's what
I'm thinking yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
okay but um man it just was insane
because they that gamm could
have like sold us to another label if
they didn't want us right you know what
I'm saying or got some override you know
what I mean like here you guys can have
but we're getting points you know they
let us walk you know what I mean
probably better for you they didn't even
I don't think they even knew our
attorney was like yo it's two weeks
Death Jam hasn't resigned yet you know
and then he's like yo it's a week you
know and then he's like y they didn't
resign right and he's like um don't say
nothing uh he's like don't say anything
we'll let a week pass and then we'll
notify him that we're leaving we're
leaving we're gone you know what I mean
not that we wanted to leave it's just to
we yeah they just became everything
Chang